[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es wieder ein rezept zum
thema oktoberfest ich glaub ich glaube
man kann sie kennen ja man könnte ja
aber wie gerät nicht weil ich ja und so
schlägt er hat den zuschauern
wahrscheinlich auch ja ich habe mir
heute gedacht was ist das typische auf
dem oktoberfest natürlich sind das
lebkuchenherzen die mit aufschrift wo
einfache botschaft draufsteht und die
werden wir heute selbst backen
die habe ich jetzt dekoriert die hier
vorne hat samira dekoriert also das ist
auch eine super idee um einfach eure
kinder auch zu beschäftigen um was für
oma und opa zu basteln oder für den papa
und so weiter und baumjohann murad
mohammed ja jedenfalls müssen meine hier
noch an trocknen und sobald sie dann
trocken sind kann man hier so ein faden
durch stecken also durch wedeln und dann
kann man das ganze verschenken und auch
aufhängen
man kann sie natürlich auch aufessen die
sind super lecker aber ich finde so zum
verschenken und dann auf essen dpa lno
rund 95 wir wünschen genau das
oktoberfest wissen genau dass wir so
genau und dieser so trocken
ja die sind halt auch ein bisschen älter
und rätselt ganz frisch so sehen sie
übrigens blancos ja man kann sehr
natürlich gestalten wie man möchte
ich zeige ich jetzt einfach mal die
zutaten für den lebkuchenteig und
starten dann und starte dann direkt
servus für den teig brauche ich 100
gramm butter 225 gramm honig 125 kommt
zucker eineinhalb teelöffel
lebkuchengewürz eine prise salz und
einen halben teelöffel backpulver 15
gramm kakaopulver 600 gramm mehl und ein
ei genau dafür nehmen wir jetzt sei erst
einmal die butter die kommt in den topf
gemeinsam mit dem honig und der honig
gibt ja den lebkuchen den richtig
leckeren geschmack
hab ich gemacht
macht aber nix hier noch dazu kommt rein
und jetzt kann ich das ganze einfach bei
niedriger stufe schmelzen lassen
[Musik]
jetzt ist die masse geschmolzen jetzt
kann ich hier das mehl bereits in meiner
rührschüssel geben
dazu kommen lebkuchengewürz backpulver
und salz
du machst kakaopulver rein und das ei
und ich schütte dann die warme masse
dazu okay und jetzt vor sich
und jetzt einfach den teig verkneten
den teig habe ich jetzt kurz mit den
händen zusammen geknetet wenn einmal zu
trocken ist dann einfach die hände
befeuchten so habe ich es eben gemacht
und kurz zusammen kneten
jetzt gebe ich ihnen hier rein decken ab
und dann muss auch so etwa vier stunden
bei raumtemperatur um ihr könnt ihr noch
gerne in den kühlschrank geben aber
danach müsst ihr ihn rechtzeitig wieder
rausholen etwa eine stunde bevor ihn
verwenden möchte denn ansonsten wird
dazu fest es ist nichts war leider kurz
warten
ok nach der wartezeit habe ich jetzt den
teig noch mal kurzen durchgeknetet und
jetzt nämlich tölzer diesem 5 mm dick
und da kann ich jetzt den teig schön
ausrollen und so wieder einfach schön
gleichmäßig und die herzlichen backen
auch gut durch
[Musik]
und jetzt könnt ihr entweder große herz
ausstecher nehmen oder ihr könnt euch
auch eine schablone aus papier basteln
und mit hilfe der schablone einfach
herzchen ausschneiden
jetzt müssen wir immer gucken dass wir
nicht so viel teig verschwinden hatte
jetzt hier am besten in die ecke ja wir
machen jetzt ein paar große und ein paar
kleine
[Musik]
und jetzt lege ich die kleinen auf 1
gleich und die großen auf ein separates
bleche man einfach weiter eine
unterschiedliche backzeit haben okay ein
mini herz und den restlichen teig kneten
wir jetzt noch einmal zusammen und
stechen noch ein paar weitere herze aus
[Musik]
und so kommen die herzchen jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad ober
unterhitze etwa 12 bis 15 minuten und
relais koren herzen sind gebacken
wichtig ist dass sie direkt nach dem
backen eingestochen werden und zwar habe
ich jetzt dafür eine loch töne verwendet
und habe zwei löcher eingestochen
einfach dafür dass wir sie später eben
auch schild aufhängen können wenn man
sie nicht aufhängen möchte dann brauchen
wir natürlich keine löcher jetzt sind
sie bereits abgekühlt dafür haben wir
sie auf ein achtel gitter gelegt und
jetzt kann der große hergestellt werden
ich zeige euch jetzt zwei varianten wir
verwenden noch beide und zwar nehme ich
jetzt einmal weiß dass jetzt ein
frisches ei weiß das gebe ich hier in
die schüsse da kommt jetzt 250 gramm
puderzucker dazu und etwa 1 teelöffel
zitronensaft
[Musik]
das wird jetzt schön verrührt und da
muss man jetzt darauf achten dass der
große auch nicht zu flüssig ist denn ich
möchte ihn ja gleich spritzen und je
nachdem wofür man ihn verwendet muss
jetzt ein bisschen dicker oder bisserl
dünnflüssiger sein wenn ihr damit gerne
schreiben möchte dann sollte einen tick
dünnflüssiger sein
ich werde ihn jetzt aber gleich
verwenden um mit einer spritze schüler
die bordüre zu spritzen
daher dafür ein bisschen dickflüssiger
bleiben
[Musik]
den teil ich jetzt auch drei kleine
schildchen auf
[Musik]
jetzt nehmen wir lebensmittel verpassten
und können damit den gruß einfärben und
verpassten deswegen weil ihr die
konsistenz nicht verändern
ihr solltet auf keinen fall flüssige
farben verwenden die sind zum einen
nicht deckend genug und zum anderen
verändern sie einfach die konsistenz und
damit der kurs viel zu flüssig okay du
kriegst bisschen grün
wir machen schöne pastellfarben
[Musik]
denn kurz habe ich jetzt zur seite
gestellt und natürlich abgedeckt damit
er nicht austrocknet jetzt machen wir
erst einmal die schrift und dafür nehmen
wir jetzt hier die zucker schrift die
haben jetzt bereits weit geknetet und
dies ganz praktisch weil sie einfach in
natur drin steckt und ich kann jetzt
damit wie mit einem stift einfach malen
und zeichnen also durchaus gestalte
deine lebkuchen herren und so war es
auch
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt so weit fertig jetzt wird
nur noch der rand den zuckerguss habe
ich jetzt in einen einweg spritzbeutel
gefühlt und hier fordern eine kleine
tool ich nehm jetzt einmal diese tolle
das ist eine gezackte thüle und gleich
verwende ich noch diese stelle
und jetzt werde ich einfach in kleinen
wellenbewegungen den rand auf spritzen
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt die lebkuchenherzen aus
ich finde sie sind wirklich super süß
geworden die müssen wir jetzt natürlich
erst mal antrocknen lassen befördern
so ein geschenk bank durch kommt und
dann werde ich sie verschenken ja echt
schön
vor allem macht das echt spaß ich finde
oktoberfest könnte das ganze jahr sein
unser team ist natürlich auch ganz
vorbildlich bekleidet kommt man alle her
ja wie man sich nicht mal zeige heute
morgen alle um 8 30 uhr vor der tür
gestanden
tom in lederhose an die im dirndl vom
wetter her hier dass der markt auch in
lederhose nur demokrat hat noch kein
outfit da ist uns noch darum kümmern
dass murat ist muss man hinter der
kamera stehen
die im zimmer dies bereitet durch er
kein dirndl gekauft jeweiligen preisen
ja ich hole dir noch einen verlierer
oder magnet 1 sehr hübsch city aus das
müssen wir noch gleich selbst und fotos
machen kommen wieder an die arbeit
zurück das war ein kurzer auftritt aber
sehr schön
ihr habt mir wir machen übrigens im
anschluss oktoberfest geben waghäusel
sommerhauses ja falls ihr das rezept
nach machen möchtet dann schaut auf
meinem blog vorbei aufs element de
da steht noch mal alles ganz genau falls
ihr fragt wie lange die lebkuchenherzen
haltbar sind also im prinzip werde die
jetzt gar nicht mal schlecht die sind
jetzt für immer haltbar
wir müssen jetzt einfach gut
durchtrocknen lassen und dann verpacken
damit sie nicht ein schrauben in
klarsichtfolie zum beispiel
aber natürlich sind sie irgendwann
steinhart als irgendwann kann man es ja
nicht mehr essen und bricht sich
wahrscheinlich alle zähne aus denn aber
frisch sind sie natürlich sehr lecker
ist noch was sagen nein ich bin
schockiert
ok ich fand's lustig oder
ja ich fand es auch noch studieren also
wir hatten alle viel spaß wünschen euch
viel spaß beim nachmachen und bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss kann jetzt andreas
gabalier laufen lassen und alle tanzen
warum jetzt macht's gut der österreicher
macht nächstes macht mehr auf schlager
fahrt ist das oktoberfest spanisch alles
das gleiche aber auch diese ausgelaufen
[Musik]
ja ich backe backe
die gucken vielleicht blick nach vorn
steht
das war überhaupt nicht mein kopf
von meinem kuchen vorliegt
[Musik]